[Music]
the russian troops are getting closer
and closer to the capital
they're now only eight kilometers away
with the ukrainian military desperately
trying to stop russian soldiers who are
pressing into the centre of urban
[Music]
the sounds of street by street fighting
and thud of war is a constant inside the
town
and in the middle of this all there are
terrified civilians
hundreds gingerly making their way
across a bombed bridge hastily patched
together with a makeshift walkway
most are women and children gripping
each other's hands holding their pets
close
among them too many elderly clasping the
only possessions they've managed to grab
it's all they have left in the world now
there are ukrainian soldiers trying to
guide them across they know they're just
ahead of the advancing russian troops
and the window to get them to safety is
narrowing
you see that putin attacking children
putin attacking elderly people putin
attacking
women's and this is no any rules of law
he is a military crime
there's no humanitarian corridor here
and no real safe place this is only the
next staging post
and the sounds of war aren't lessening
instead they're getting louder and
following them
they're exhausted and spent
and often weeping with relief
or just glad to be alive
they're very stressed tell me quickly
are you all right i'm all right it was
in car
and we saw this better russian better
he's he strikes on us
and we
his gods now save us god save us
the russian army is leaving a trail of
despair and destruction as it cuts its
way through to the capital
aerial footage of butcher another town
on the outskirts of kiev showed burning
vehicles and abandoned russian hardware
a stream of ukrainian soldiers emerged
from urban looking drained of all energy
and defeated
it looked like it had been a tough
battle
those picking up the fight know it will
not be easy and some who escaped had
hair-raising tails
did you see the russian soldiers are
they close enough you saw them how many
were there what they what were they
doing i saw just like maybe two or three
people and they was just so i just like
right
from there i didn't wanted to watch it
can you work out what they're trying to
attack are they attacking everything is
asian food just
something special i i guess they should
in every everything they see
so
so
yeah
what have they tied you up with
oh my gosh do they they think they think
you were russian
probably yes but we have all documents
we can prove that we are not russians we
are
ukrainians
a ukrainian soldier investigates and
questions them and they produce their
passports any young man not fighting is
viewed with great suspicion
but he's satisfied they are ukrainians
and cuts him free
those who fled are now desperately
hoping they can reach sanctuary
but it seems the russian military is
moving relentlessly forward and they're
being transported into the capital a few
kilometers away where they fear they'll
be next
inside kiev there's non-stop work to try
to shore up defenses and protect
themselves amidst increasingly strident
demands for international help
we are on our own land in our country
and we will fight for this country
in
every town in every city
on each
street from the each building we are
ready and we will fight because we are
the truth on our side and the gut on our
side
so we will win
they're calling for a no-fly zone but
with the world looking on now all they
can do is wait for an army they fear
will inevitably arrive
alex crawford sky news kiev